ちなみに、アメリカの嫌悪感については、新しいスクリプトが登場し
ます。ストーリーモード全体のようにストリートファイター5を除外した機能の数は、
約1時間で終了できるのではないでしょうか。
右のサーバーも非常に遅れていますえ
えと、ロビーは
今のところ2人のプレーヤーしかサポートし
ていませんうん、アーケードモードのない格闘ゲームのアーケードモードの悲痛なリリースには含まれていませんでした
とはいえ
、ゲームが今後の大きなトーナメントなどに間に合うようにするための機能がたくさん省略されていると聞いたのですが
、それは進化するプラットフォームのように
、たくさんのキャラクターを持ち上げてさらに
証明するようなものです 私のポイント
suckaは、この強気に
とてもうんざりしていることを面白く
考えれば、ゲーマーはこれを許すだろうと真剣に考えて
いますが、ゲーマーと呼ばれることさえありません
。 カプコンの開発者
は、コアキャラクターをもっと
有効にしたのは理にかなっていると思っていますが、もう何も理にかなっていないのです。
Kickstarterの仕組み
はあなたが8人か
どうか、カプコンが来週にパッチを当てない場合、サッカーの不足についてIsisに通知する予定です。
これは公開情報です。今では、ある
女の子が妹のようだったスクリプトについて 私は
あなたが育ったことはありませんでしたあなたには
彼女の名前のケイティデジタルジェノサイドがあります
私たちが彼女に会ったときにカプコンが私の妹の男を殺した
方法
スコープが来るそれが来る
彼らは彼女を切り取ることができない